hier sprechen wir mit christian der
matzdorf ist professor für kriminalistik
und kriminaltechnik schön dass sie bei
uns sind hermsdorf so viele fragen zu
diesem grausamen fall vor allem die
frage wie konnte es dazu kommen der
täter bereits vorbestraft war in einem
programm für wiedereingliederung da
sollte man auch an dem er ist die ganze
zeit unter beobachtung und den behörden
müsse auffallen wenn der sich im
internet mit einem jungen mädchen
verabredet
ja die wahrheit ist und das ist etwas
was vielleicht gar nicht so bewusst sein
hier steht dass es keine lückenlose rund
um die uhr haut geben kann wir haben
hunderte wenn nicht tausende von
sexualstraftätern in der bundesrepublik
die beobachtet werden müssten
theoretisch rund um die uhr wir haben
noch andere aufgaben die polizei
wahrnehmen muss beispielsweise
terroristische gefährder ähnliches es
gibt keine lückenlose überwachung rund
um die uhr dass der erste wichtige
fakten dieser angelegenheit das weiteren
natürlich unverständlich dass ein mensch
der schon schwere straftaten begangen
hat hier gerade in diesem bereich
sexualdelikten an kindern dann die
möglichkeit hat taten zu begehen das
liegt daran dass die justiz eine
entscheidung treffen muss das gutachten
eine entscheidung treffen und dass die
justiz am ende dann auch sein treffen
muss ob die freiheitsrechte diesen
menschen höher einzuschätzen das
gefährdungsrisiko diese entscheidung
sind oftmals sehr umstritten und auch
für mich häufig nicht nachvollziehbar
wenn man ein risiko für die
allgemeinheit über die freiheitsrechte
den einzelnen betroffenen straftäter
gestellt also aline ist offenbar opfer
einer fehleinschätzung eines gutachtens
geworden
man müsste jetzt den gesamten prozess
betrachten dazu braucht man ein
intensives aktenstudium das kann nicht
von hier aus nicht leisten darüber kann
davon ausgehen dass ein mensch der in
haft gesessen hat ob es jetzt strafhaft
da bisschen maßregelvollzug gezogen hat
sei dahingestellt dass der an einem
bestimmten punkt entweder im rahmen des
urteils wenn zb keine
sicherungsverwahrung angeordnet worden
ist oder im nachhinein dann durch eine
gutachterliche aussage eine prognose
bekommen hat die aussagt das risiko ist
vorhanden aber nicht so groß dass man
ihn nicht in freiheit entlassen kann
dass man ein risiko gesehen hat sieht
man daran dass die polizei mit dem fall
befasst war ich hätte eigentlich irgend
eine überprüfung der aktivitäten im
internet eines solchen mannes statt oder
kann der im internet egal was er vorher
begangen hat zunächst einmal tun und
lassen was er will
wir haben in der bundesrepublik ein
ich würde etwas sagen umgangssprachlich
eine heilige kuh dass der datenschutz
oder sind die freiheitsrechte der person
das recht auf informelle
selbstbestimmung an sich eine gute sache
die hier gar nicht bestritten werden
soll tatsache ist aber dass das die
möglichkeiten ermittlungsbehörden
ganzheitlich beschneidet und
beispielsweise eine überwachung auch der
internet aktivitäten einer person so gar
nicht möglich macht bzw auch technisch
gar nicht möglich ist wann hast du
schnell bei dem alten satz den auch der
altkanzler gerhard schröder mal gesagt
hat wegsperren für immer jetzt einmal
ganz sachlich gefragt lassen sich solche
männer solche sexualstraftäter
tatsächlich nach abgesessener haftstrafe
wieder eingliedern also vor kann sowas
funktionieren dass sie ganz normal unter
uns leben oder eben nicht straffällig
werden
menschen mit einer sexuellen
orientierung die nicht therapierbar ist
die nur beispielsweise demand
medikamentöse haben dann griff bekommen
werden kann können nicht geheilt werden
kann noch nicht als geheilt entlassen
werden es kommt sehr stark auf die tat
anders kommt darauf an ob es sich um
einen menschen mit einer fehl-
orientierung handelt oder ob dahinter
gründe vorliegen grundsätzlich muss man
sagen dass immer ein risiko besteht und
dieses risiko individuell einzuschätzen
ist ein bisschen wie in einer glaskugel
lesen das kann man nie vorhersehen man
sollte allerdings überlegen ob man nicht
tatsächlich die den schutz der
gesellschaft vor den freiheitsrechten
der person in der abwägung geben
zugunsten der gesellschaft und weniger
im einzelfall dann für das risiko dass
ein straftäter eine weitere straftat
begeht hier ausspricht das ist das was
mich beschäftigt
vielen herzlichen danke ihnen für das
gespräch
[Musik]